in our series looking forward to 2021
we're taking a wide-ranging look
at what we can expect next year
everything from politics to travel
to education you know the pandemic has
exposed dramatic inequalities in the
american public school system
there's a report by common sense media
that says an estimated 15 to 16 million
k-12 students live in homes with poor
or no internet connection or don't have
adequate devices for proper remote
learning
randy white garden is president of the
american federation of teachers that is
the union representing 1.7 million
teachers
and other school professionals randy
good to see you
it's great to see you david i hope
you're safe i am and you too
uh listen let's start with the vaccine
right so frontline workers are receiving
it now
when do you think teachers will be next
to receive
well you know we're we're hopeful that
after healthcare workers and nursing
home
patients and staff that teachers
will be next in line you know with other
essential workers
and we push the cdc for that over the
course of the last few months we'd love
to see you know school
opening and vaccines align together
we're concerned that
you know the the trump administration
did not get out
as many vaccines as they said that they
would
and that that's one more thing that's
going to be left for the biden
administration
and we're you know hopeful we're glad
that um president-elect biden said
yesterday
that he would use the defense production
act to get more vaccine
you know two people um but i do think
that we can
reopen in-person learning
once one tackles this current surge
without waiting for everyone to get
vaccinated
i think we can you know use testing
as a key early warning measure
because we need to reopen our school
buildings and we need to keep people
safe
miss weingarten sharika duncan here we
know that 54 billion dollars from that
coronavirus relief package is going to
schools k through 12. where do you think
that money needs to be spent especially
after hearing that
15 to 16 million k-12 students don't
even have access to internet or poor
internet
uh and kind of going back to the vaccine
do you think teachers should be mandated
to take it
look i i so first of jerica if um please
call me randy
all right only my students call me
that's wine garden okay out of respect
but so no i i appreciate it
um but um so the david's laughing the
bottom line is this
you can't let me let me let me get to
the mandate
issue right now in america you have to
create
um um you know truth is earned
and trust is er i mean trust is earned i
wish truth was obvious
but trust is earned and so we have to
show people
that the vaccine is credible and it's
real
and you know so i would put that issue
about whether you
mandate it off to the side for a second
i want to see
a hundred percent of t educators take it
and i want to see a hundred percent
of kids take it as soon as it is um
you know as soon as it's been proven
effective and you know dr
fauci has said that we need 80 to 90
percent
of of people taking it for us to create
herd immunity but
there's no there there's so many fights
in america right now
we don't need to have that fight right
now and frankly there's a lot of history
of distrust in communities of color
about vaccines
and so let's actually create the trust
um
and so that's um but in terms of
schooling itself you know and and the
money
look we had been pushing for state and
federal funds
which frankly state and local funds fund
basically half of schooling so the fact
that the
federal the fact that the republicans
and mr trump refused to do that
means that there's still a huge hole
does 54 billion go a long way
of course it does but let's measure
against what the cdc has said
finally that it costs to get the
safeguards in
and it said and they say it costs about
four hundred dollars uh
a student so if you're thinking about
what schools need
and i'm sorry it's a laundry list but
like you know when i came to cbs this
morning
everybody's doing the same thing it's
physical distancing
it's everybody's wearing their ppe or
their mass
it's good ventilation it's good cleaning
and then on top of that
testing which is a really important
early warning system
that will help us reopen schools that
kind of package
of safeguards costs money randy let's
talk about roadblocks and priorities
with the biden administration right so
your organization
endorsed president-elect biden you
campaigned for the senate candidates
in georgia have you spoken to the biden
administration about what you'd like to
see
as some of the first things to tackle
such as
kids having internet especially those
students
yes i have and frankly you know
we you know so we've spoken to them i've
written about a blueprint
in in november and in december about
what we need
but it is a sin david that 16 million
kids do not have internet we're a year
into this pandemic
and frankly what all kids need
is a high speed internet so in in
suburbs and cities across the country
high speed internet exists but it costs
money and and and kids and their parents
should get it for free and and and it
shouldn't have taken a pandemic for that
to happen
now randy there's some money in the new
covet relief bill
but we need more and we need one more
thing i would say is that we need
something like the tva that roosevelt
did
for electrification we need a broadband
push in rural areas randy thank you i'm
told we are out of time good to see you
happy new year sorry
you too david